oh mein gott sollte seit monaten habe
ich nicht mehr auf hilf mir reagiert die
vorzeige schlechthin auf rtl meinem
absoluten lieblingsländer bis heute war
wieder der moment gekommen wo ich mir
gedacht habe hey leute heute muss mal
wieder qualitativen bildungs
intellektueller konnte auf seinem kanal
kommende entwickelte damen und herren
heute reagiere ich auf helfen wir
doktorspiele krankenschwester stehen
auch oberarzt
ich habe gar keinen bock
krankenschwester peggy hat ein auge auf
dr fahrten geworfen leider ist er
bereits an die oberschwester kathrin
vergeben peggy scheint das nicht zu
stören da wissen wir genau was heute
wieder abgehen wird allerdings würde ich
sagen kriegen wir mal direkt auf play
und stürzen uns in das doktorspiele
abenteuer erste szene erste szene
ich weiß warum ich mir diese serie seit
monaten nicht angeschaut habe also das
ist ja eine schauspielleistung alter die
grenze an erdkern ich musste noch mit
ihm gegen die hat aber sofort
hat die ärztin sie nicht gerade gefragt
was machen sie hier daraufhin hat die
krankenschwester doch einfach nur
geantwortet und wollte sagen was sie da
macht und dann sagt die ärztin wieder
fragt doch er ist gerne helm 840 sind
daher auch hilft mir ja krass das muss
unbedingt eine einblendung auf meinem
kanal werden ja fast
[Applaus]
die oberärztin macht hin wie mit dem
doktor um dann die krankenschwester
platz da rein jetzt fährt die gegenden
wagen voller medikamente
es ist krank aus aller zeiten ich bin
gerade beim oberarzt im zimmer gekommen
und da hat er ernsthaft mit der
überschüsse also
mit der oberschwester wie sowie das denn
sie haben vor ein paar monaten
geheiratet
also die sind verheiratet die darum
gemacht haben das erklärt natürlich
einige sagt erwarten ist ja auch echt
geil ich würde ihn auch nicht von der
bettkante stoßen
sie ist doch irgendwie 25 oder so und
dieser doktor bartender locker 50 ja
also menschenrechte sind sämtlich
abstoßen am nächsten morgen peggy will
ihren chef de erwarten um jeden preis
ich finde das t shirt von ihr das leben
ist kein ponyhof durch die griechen
nichts wert das ist wieder so eine folge
habe ich einfach klatschen durch mein
zimmer laufclub drittel klinik kennis
mit boris nutzer hatte ihre beleidigung
bei tante marianne gelernt oder was ja
genau
natürlich alles gute mama und die mama
bedankt sich dafür dass die tochter
daran gedacht hat also das ist natürlich
schon eine aufgabe dass man sich den
geburtstag der mutter merkt ich wünsche
dir alles alles gute für diesen job dass
das gericht die klappt und du richtig
durchstarten kannst die aus unserer
familie der wirklich was toll ist mach
was aber er schafft das was eine hilfe
mutter ich finde es gut dass perrys
mutter sie dabei unterstützt den
bescheidenen familiären verhältnissen zu
entkommen
und wenn sie ihr bestes gibt dann
schafft sie das ja danke schön nochmal
für deine einstellt sondern an der
stelle aber sie sollte die finger von
ihrem oberarzt lassen also ich weiß echt
nicht was wir ohne sie machen würden in
unseren reactions an der stelle möchte
aber noch mal ganz kurz anmerken ich
weiß ich sage das in jeder reaktion und
ihr faktor ich auch schon mittlerweile
darüber ab allerdings ist wirklich meine
komplette reaktion alles was ich sage
wenn ich mich über leute dort kaputt
lache sage ich mal es ist alles ironisch
gemeint und bezieht sich auf die
geschauspielert rolle also niemals gegen
die leute die die echten personen hinter
den gespielten rollen sind ich denke
jeder sollte wissen dass komplett hilf
mir und die meisten sendungen im
fernsehen ehe gescriptet sind da sind
alle schauspieler die dort spielen
deswegen geht es wenn ich lache nie
gegen die personen hinter den rollen
also ich möchte hier mit niemandem
stress haben oder irgendwie sowas ist
alles rein lustig humorvoll und ironisch
zu verstehen schauen jetzt mal wie es im
krankenhaus weiter geht also da wo
grundsätzlich alle medikamente auf dem
boden verteilt werden
30 minuten später kevin oberarzt daniel
denn eine krankenschwester so sich
anzieht und obwohl er verheiratet ist
scheint der 49-jährige nicht abgeneigt
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich aber gespannt wollte ich
nur dass ich bin uns liegen sehen habe
schon mal ganz gut ich hab heute abend
dienst eingeteilt das ist okay wir uns
großen spaß mit ihm zusammen zu rücken
war dass wir nicht so zieht man ein
bisschen mit ihnen zu tun haben werden
verschmitzt ich erwarte ihn fünf minuten
um kleinere in fünf minuten sehen sie
das wir haben 123 de nach hier gegeben
sie ist da was das ist oder acht
natürlich vereins nimmt
blutdrucksenkenden mittel ich habe so
das gefühl dass diese oberschwester
kathrin also die die mit dem doktor
baten zusammen ist dass sie jetzt sie
irgendwie rausschmeißen will
und so erwarten
ja ich komme immer noch nicht auf die
vorstellung klar zukunft erwarte ich
normale kleidung ja wir sind hier nicht
im alter ok krass also sie machte die in
der ordentliche ansage der ständige
kampf mit oberschwester kathrin und ihr
gefühlschaos um dr banken und machen der
26-jährigen schwerzen 26 sie und sie
will was von einem
naja also ihr seht ihr wie alt er ist ja
da muss ich richtig sagen das war's
wirklich komplett freundin ja hallo
hallo ja kommen hatten schon das motto
hallo die echt mega geil is better damen
fahrstuhlschacht das wetter
[Musik]
krass
ich will fällt mir fällt da gar nichts
mehr zu ein geradezu warten was sind
ihre frau
das wird lange scheißegal panasonic hat
unser kleines geheimnis
[Musik]
ach du scheiße also
und jetzt steckt er auch mein gott was
denken sie okay das ist mein gott ich
komme nicht klar auf diese folge
ich habe übrigens ein neues die schon
anders kommt am 16
ist mir gerade so aufgefallen als ich in
dem bildschirm geguckt haben uns weiß
dass hier eines der fünf säulen produkte
die am ersten sechs leichen werden in
meinem shop um 15 uhr
das ist ein weißes t-shirt etwas abseits
schnitt mit der schrift luke room at
darauf den genauen hintergrund hinter
dem kollektions gedanken you better
erzähle ich euch noch in dem anderen
video ist finde ich ganz cool
ganz schön und sie haben und auch eine
sehr schöne aktion hinter dem launch
zusammen gedacht werde ich euch das
ganze noch mal in einem separaten video
die nächsten tage irgendwann erzählen
ich bin jetzt erst mal gespannt wie das
da weitergeht übernehmen die nachricht
von der müller waren die fehler des
nicht heute geleistet haben altern das
geht manchmal meine mutter vermutlich
muss auf ihr erstes hat die namen
geburtstag und zweitens hat doktor baten
auch nachtschicht als normal auf die
mutter alter ich will einfach wissen was
man da warten jetzt noch passiert
das ist dass es mir fällt in dieser
folge 10.000 mal wieder auf warum ich
nicht mehr auf hilfe reagiert habe sie
bekommt ihr nacktbild von doktor paten
gewendet
ich weiß ganz genau was man da ist ja
das schöne an staus
also was in dieser folge alles passiert
ist ja wahnsinn nur jemand warten doch
warten lange zu mir haben sie mich
gerufen
ich wollte ja ich war jetzt sofort alter
ich komme also
wird das video jetzt 18
wie man sieht nur wie zwei menschen sich
hier gerade kürzen aber es ist halt so
es ist sogar etwas zu ende bringen was
für einen aufzug angefangen haben sind
der marktleute ich guck mir eigentlich
videos immer bis zum ende an aber hier
muss ich wirklich sagen lasst mich in
ruhe damit wenn ihr wollt dass ich mir
den rest der folge noch anschaue dann
schreibt man in die kommentare aber ich
brauche an der stelle jetzt erst mal
eine ordentliche psychiatrie
[Musik]